[Applause]
oscar's popping off
i didn't even know it was happening
until i looked at twitter that
well at night so i didn't even know
movies came out this year
i was like what what movies like who's
first of all actually before i need to
give a huge shout out to our boy van
lathan
oh tmz ex tmz employee van lee best
thing that could ever happen was leaving
tmz so he could win a [ __ ] oscar
that's wild yeah so shout out to van
that's my brother i love you man i'm so
proud of you and uh it's just so great
to see and
yeah it's just it's just his journey's
been awesome to watch and uh
and yeah it's just great that's just
great short film doc has stock it's
called two distant strangers yeah so
yeah yeah yeah look out for that um so
check that out man check out van show
love to van man
um but what were you saying about the
oscars in general i just had no idea i
just think it's getting
more and more irrelevant every year and
it's so funny to watch these actors
still think they matter and do their
[ __ ]
social chants whenever they win an award
and nobody cares
yeah it is funny like well ready for the
numbers yeah
officially the lowest oscar viewership
in history under 10 million and
last year was the all-time low of like
23 million
so it's dropped that drastically low and
this was directed
that or put together produced by steven
soderbergh who like
brought you the ocean's franchise like
you think like all right he's going to
shake it up
garbage still three hours no monologues
no
no sauce nothing you know why i love
watching actors lose
is because they swear they're for the
people and then they all put on ten
thousand dollar outfits
to be for the people where they go to
this award show and the people are
literally caged off
and they walk a royal red carpet like
kings and queens and then they go into a
[ __ ] castle and lock the door and
then you watch them
pat themselves on the back like kings
and queens you're not for the people
you are kings and queens pretending even
to add to that i'm pretty sure that the
city of los angeles like bust out
homeless people and got them away from
the venue that they were having this is
so
this is so funny and the city displaced
the homeless from that area right yeah
and and then i believe best picture or
something like that or
one of the what was it it was the best
picture best picture
was a movie about homelessness it's just
no bad luck
they bust out they they sweep away the
homeless they go in with their
sweep away the tents sweep away the
homeless so that they can give out a
reward
for a movie about homelessness and the
crisis that that is
it's unbelievable the fact that you
think you have the right to get
political it's
it's infuriating to me like you have no
you have no ground to stand on you're
the most out of touch person on earth
yeah
yeah yeah i [ __ ] hate actors
you just talk for a living but you don't
even like what you'll do i mean
yeah what does that watch what does that
say about hollywood that all these uh
all the like the oscars are tanking and
all these other like award shows they're
thinking
it's over baby well i think you could
say in terms of that's that's decreased
in terms of like
i i guess importance but people still
are loving content more than ever
they're just finding in different ways
and it's like
all right we don't really care about the
fame in a certain way that's why
when you watch content on tv like you
talk almost less about actors and
someone saying
that show is great with these you know
these brits you've never seen in your
life
and so that's it that's that's writers
and directors and that's going to come
up and there's a lot more voices that
can be seen
i mean if you think about it all of the
winners
it's the the ones who really controlled
it were netflix
like hulu that's where you can see all
these films i mean they're still
controlled by some of the studios but
yeah and is that just taking over covid
is that just like
this year is in particularly bizarre
because i don't know sure it didn't
help theaters like i have no clue any of
the films that were nominated this year
i mean do you guys know there was like
this big there's this big beef over uh
because chadwick boseman r.i.p didn't
win
and anthony hopkins won yeah or best
actor right soon to be r.i.p
right let's be honest about this oh
anthony hopkins probably yeah
he's going off numbers here um actuary
table oh that's actually the funniest
guy on social media you should follow
whoever he's having
he's a 20 20 year old wild boy so here's
my point though right
people are upset that chadwick bozeman
didn't win right how many people
saw the anthony hopkins movie the father
i didn't even know that movie existed i
don't even know what chadwick boson was
nominated for black panther what was he
nominated for
no no rainey's black bottom yeah
i mean like i don't even know these
movies i have no clue so people are
getting like
outraged about it like be honest you
didn't see any of them none of us saw
movies this year
yeah i wish i didn't yeah you would have
thought that they would have because
everything's available
and it used to be i wish i didn't see a
goddamn movie this year i'll tell you
that much so one too many [ __ ] movies
call back to last episode yeah i guess
i mean just i'm tired of it bro i'm just
tired
yeah the only one i saw was uh judas and
the black messiah and i thought that was
i heard it was amazing yeah
did that win anything yeah uh david
kulaya or whatever however you say his
name he won for best supporting actor
that's cool yeah and he's a hell of a
[ __ ] actor great actor but
i can't tell you he did better than
anybody else because i didn't see [ __ ]
nobody saw [ __ ]
yeah and you would have thought that
they would have figured out how to like
really market those films because
typically with the normal oscars those
movies don't get a big release they wait
for the oscars you see the winners and
then
they go in a bigger theatrical release
this time it's like they're all
streaming they could have done a push
everyone would have been ready to see it
nope nope just they also were depressing
dramas like
it was yeah you know people that were
they were already like
put more pressing [ __ ] out like come on
b yeah they need dana white to promote
the oscars
yeah you know who had it right back in
the day was mtv movie awards
they killed it kill talk [ __ ] to
everybody make fun of everybody have
sketches making fun of everything
and then just let fans vote and we're
not going to be happy with it because
fans are stupid but at least his fans
yeah you just can't have antics like
that anymore well even mtv [ __ ] [ __ ]
they started thinking they started like
thinking it was important
like they stopped thinking the award
show was a joke and they started
thinking it was actually something
serious yeah and then they just ruined
the whole [ __ ] thing yep
i mean whatever that's the problem when
these goofy start taking themselves
seriously man it is
it's a damn damn shame um all right what
about mortal kombat al you just saw it
oh yeah i saw mortal kombat it was
yeah i gave it like two out of five
really but
you know nostalgia was cool sub-zero
character yeah it was
like sub-zero and the scorpion like
character there back and forth that was
that made the movie
yeah yeah outside of that i was like
yeah how was raiden
yeah trash really yeah like it looked
like the cgi for his eyes like
we could have did that on [ __ ] that
bad yeah
and the first mortal kombat was so lit
when we were kids oh my god
these times this one is worse because i
[ __ ] graphics should be way better
was it traumatizing to see the movie
after i whooped your ass in mortal
kombat when we were in
north carolina are you lying like you
know you go to hell when you lie like
you